>> Dana: NEW YORK CITY ART
GALLERY UNVEILING A NEW PAINTING
BY HUNTER BIDEN AND THE SALE
PRICE IS $250,000.
THAT'S A LOT.
>> THAT'S BIG MONEY.
IF YOU THINK THE PRICE IS HIGH,
YOU SHOULD MEET THE PAINTER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
COME ON NOW.
BUT THE REASON THIS DOES LOOK
BAD.
NO ADMINISTRATION HAS CARED LESS
ABOUT OPTICS THAN THIS ONE.
I THINK THE BELIEF IS THEY DON'T
EXPECT BACKLASH FROM THE PRESS.
PRIOR TO JOE BIDEN BECOMING THE
PRESIDENT, THERE WAS NO MARKET
FOR HUNTER BIDEN, OKAY?
HE WASN'T A KNOWN COMMODITY IN
THE ART WORLD.
THE ONLY THING HE WAS KNOWN FOR
IS PAINTING THE TOWN, OKAY?
THERE WAS NO DEMAND FOR THIS.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE RIDICULOUS
THAT THEY MIGHT BE PEDDLING A
LITTLE INFLUENCE HERE AND THIS
VERY MUCH OVERLAPS WITH THE
ACCUSATION IN THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOPS THAT THEY TRADED ON THE
NAME.
THEY SEEM TO BE DOING THAT HERE.
>> Bill: YOU ARE TWO FOR TWO.
HIS VERSION OF STARRY STARRY
NIGHT.
THE GUY RUNNING THE GALLERY SAID
BIDEN HAS BEEN A PAINTER FOR
YEARS, ALWAYS BEEN AN ARTIST.
PAINTING ON YOUR OWN AND SAYING
THAT'S HOW I'LL DO ITMENT I'M
GOING TO BE AN ARTIST.
>> I DON'T BUY THAT.
THEY AREN'T TAKING THE COMPANY
PUBLIC.
THE ONE THING IS IT'S ONLY $2
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR HUNTER.
HE HAS TO GIVE 10% OF THE SALE
TO THE BIG GUY.
>> Bill: TOPIC TWO.
NANCY PELOSI'S DAUGHTER
APPARENTLY SAYS HER MOM IS TOUGH
TO CRACK.
LICENSE HERE SOUND BITE.
>> THERE IS NO CATCHING HER
OFF GUARD.
MY LIFE'S WORK IS TRYING TO GET
HER TO GO OFF GUARD.
SHE EATS NAILS FOR BREAKFAST.
>> Dana: ICE CREAM IN THE
AFTERNOON.
>> Bill: FANCY ICE CREAM.
>> THE NICE PINT SHE HAD DURING
THE LOCKDOWN.
THE THING I LIKE ABOUT HBO, THEY
CHOSE A DIRECTOR THAT CLEARLY
DIDN'T HAVE A HORSE IN THIS RACE
CLEARLY.
HE HAS NO INTEREST IN PUSHING
THE SUBJECT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A LITTLE
RIDICULOUS.
I DON'T DOUBT PEOPLE WILL ENJOY
IT.
NANCY PELOSI IS VERY GOOD AT
GETTING THE VOTES.
I WOULDN'T WATCH THIS AT GUN
POINT.
>> Dana: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS.
ELON MUSK GOING ON THE RECORD ON
HOW HE FEELS ABOUT DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI TWEETING.
MY PRONOUNS ARE PROSECUTE/FAUCI
AND THEN THERE IS A PICTURE HE
DID THAT GOT THE FOLKS UPSET
SAYING ONE MORE LOCKDOWN, MY
KING.
>> ALSO ON A SERIOUS NOTE HE IS
RELEASING THIS INFORMATION THAT
TWITTER THROTTLED DOWN ANYONE
WHO THEY DIDN'T AGREE WITH ON
SCIENCE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
WHAT FAUCI AND WHAT HE
REPRESENTS HERE, OKAY, AND WHAT
ELON IS TRYING TO DO.
THERE IS SOME OVERLAP.
I THINK THIS IS AN UNFORCED
ERROR BY MUSK.
THE REASON HE IS SHOWING THE
LIGHT OF DAY TO THESE INTERNAL
CENSORSHIP EFFORTS WAS TO PROVE
HOW CORRUPT THE PREVIOUS REGIME
WAS.
HE IS INSERTING HIMSELF INTO THE
DEBATE BY TAKING A POLITICAL
POSITION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS WAS THE
RIGHT MOVE BUT I FIND IT REALLY
FUNNY AND AFTER THE WEEKEND I
HAD IN OKLAHOMA CITY I'M GLAD NO
ONE IS CALLING TO PROSECUTE ME.
THAT'S IT.
>> Bill: STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
HASN'T EXPIRED YET.
>> THANKS FOR NOTHING.
>> Bill: SHERIFF KNOCKING ON THE
DO